the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers we asked you to vote for the
2017 movie she wanted us to make an
honest trailer for here's your number
two choice today's episode is brought to
you by turbo tax there's nothing to be
afraid of
[Music]
forget serial killers demons and evil
clowns because a more terrifying
inescapable unstoppable force is coming
to get you rich white people get out
catch the film that proved once again
that diversity quality and making but
loads of money aren't mutually exclusive
that was the most profitable film of the
year not only because everyone bought a
ticket but because it was so low budget
they had to plug the Windows Phone wait
they make Windows Phones and it's gone
be Chris master of deflecting awkward
conversations if you really push to body
beast cool black is in fashion who's so
polite he'll stick around his
girlfriend's creepy murder house even
when people are literally screaming get
out in his face it's not a big deal
forget about it luckily there's rod one
of the best movie friends of all time
watch is the kind of guy who yells at
the screen during a horror movie she is
like a mother it's a chance to shine by
actually being inside the horror movie
man I told you not to go in the house
thank God for rod because the alternate
ending is super realistic I mean super
depressing
same difference enjoy deliciously cruel
casting that makes villains out of white
people's favorite white people turning
indie darlings west wing alums and girls
girls into a broad caricatures of
society's worst impressions of them and
if that makes you upset now you have
some inkling of how black people feel
when they watch almost every other
horror movie brothers don't last long as
situations like this seriously buy
people's main roles
or is to either die first or comment on
how often they die first the black guy
always dies first revisit all the little
details you didn't see the first time
like Rose stands up to the cops just so
they don't leave a paper trail
you don't have to give from your ideas
you ever done anything wrong the old
people drive black cars to symbolize how
they're also driving black bodies and
their victims are always wearing hats or
wigs to cover up the scars from their
surgery but then try to ignore little
details that don't add up like brains
age asbestos bodies so a transplant
wouldn't add them in years no one ever
notices all these guys went missing
after dating the same girl and why does
she live separate from the milk that's
not I think why people do is it is it so
gather round for a film that flips your
preconceived notions on its head that
progressives can be racist to the TSA
can be useful once in a while I'm TS mah
hey and getting into an interracial
relationship is a huge mistake because
you can't trust these white girls sorry
and listen a lot of lemonade damn
becky's are everywhere starring
Everybody Hates Chris always bring black
up the lost Kardashian
ben Carson keener keener keener stir
some tea sometimes your words just
hypnotize me the white wing Mumford son
and an evocative symbol of the
marginalization of black people in
America uh I mean black hole son the
stepford whites
I'm just glad this movie did well so I
finally know whose key and whose Peele I
swear it's not a race thing the show was
just key and Peele I never said which
one was which seriously I'm not a racist
in fact I would have voted for Obama a
third time if I want to voted for Obama
for a third term if I could oh no
this episode was brought to you by turbo
tax there's nothing to be afraid of
do you know Dawei Godzilla and got s T
on me
smoldering intensity very cool very cool
open the hal bay doors pod